ashley good morning how are you doing i
have a question for you
about how can i um manage my emotions
when i'm around my husband's ex-wife
uh-oh
all right tell me about it um well
fortunately
their kids are in their 20s okay right
so we don't have to do a whole lot of
um togetherness
but when we do i am just i find myself
just
angry and i recently figured out why i'm
so angry
and it's because you know she's just
constantly making comments
um belittling my husband and putting him
down so why do you
give her that kind of power to get in
your soul like that
i don't know i don't want her there
is it i don't oh great question okay so
is it my guess is it's bigger than just
comments and snide comments
my guess is that she will always be that
other woman who had a relationship with
your husband
i'm sure that that's a that's a big part
of it does he have kids with her too
i'm sorry does he have kids with her too
they have three kids together
okay how long have you and your husband
been married
um a year and a half we've been together
for five and how long were they married
20 years 20 years so yeah you're
give yourself a break you're gonna have
a
rabid forest fire worth of jealousy
burning through you for a while
okay and um you are never going to be
able to
um let me say it this way
he will all she will always have 20
years worth of relationship with the guy
that you love
on you does that make sense so if you're
married to him for 20 more years he'll
have known her for 40.
right right and that's frustrating and
like like ah you know what i mean
and at the same time the more you allow
that to take
root in your heart you're just you are
intentionally choosing to poison your
your marriage
right and that and that's that's exactly
what i don't want to do
okay um and i don't wanna i don't wanna
to get to me and i don't want to feel
that way when we have to
be in the same room together and i don't
want to let that in
gotcha and so here's how i handle those
situations
and i wish i could give you some fancy
scientific this isn't that i'm just
going to tell you how i handle it okay
um the first is i have worked for a
decade now
and especially the last two and a half
three years or so
to make my default setting kindness in
any situation
in any shape form or fashion with
whoever i'm talking to with whoever i'm
seeing
um is i will not give other people
my character i will not give other
people my emotions i almost
refuse and now i know when it rockets
out
when i just get fired up with somebody
and it happens
i mean it super happens um when it does
i know it's real then i know i'm not
just being petty and i'm being a baby or
whatever right
the second thing is is being honest with
yourself you chose to marry some
marry somebody who's been married to
someone else for 20 years and so this is
partly your not partly this is almost
entirely your choice to walk into this
deal
right right and so when you see her
it i was going to ask you so i won't do
that to you that would be mean
um when you see her intentionally choose
to exhale and drop your shoulders down
right you go first go say hi how are you
and you can own the high ground here and
if she chooses to make well did you see
steve can you believe what he's wearing
he's always wearing those belts for 20
years he's worn those belts
when that happens you can just smile and
say i think he looks great and then you
choose to walk away
right um yeah and not letting those
things in there and dude when you walk
away
your eyes are going to turn red and
you're going to get that fire
inside yourself you know what i mean
it's going to happen yeah yeah and it's
if you're not surprised by it you can
control it if you
are surprised by if your rage catches
you off guard if you're how dare you
he's my man now
you know what i mean all that kind of
jerry springer stuff if that happens
then you you are outsourcing control of
your thoughts and behaviors you're
outsourcing control of your emotions and
then
then you're subject to them right so
just know what's going to come
what does he say about it you know
what's funny is you know after this last
time i
i told him and he said well i didn't
hear what she said what did she say and
so i told him
and he said why i didn't hear it so i
don't know if he's just learned to tune
her out
you know after you know being married to
her for so long
and that he just you know there are
other things that bother him
um you know but that's those aren't it
do you feel secure in your marriage with
him absolutely
that's awesome man and if he's smart
he's gonna if he's smart when you say
can you believe what she said
in his brain he's just gonna be going
uh take a dive man just take a dive
there's that old friends episode
it's one of my favorite ever i think
rachel jennifer aniston walks out
and she's wearing something she doesn't
look great and i think she asks you know
joey
do i look good in this and chandler's
just sitting next to him and he just
goes
dude take a dive man just take a dive
and he's like trying to answer it
and so if your husband has any wisdom at
all
when you bring up her he's just going to
be like
just go back into his shell and why'd i
tell you that don't put him in that
position
right i know don't put him in that
position he chose you
he chose you and he said i
am how old is he 40 50. mid-40s
okay mid-40s he's like statistically
speaking i'm halfway or a little over
halfway there
and i'm picking i'm picking you ashley i
want to ride out this roller coaster
with you
and rest in that right and just give
yourself some time you've been together
for
a year and a half and y'all are still
newlyweds right you're still newlyweds
he just has a lot more baggage in
the you know the back of his covered
wagon than you do so um
i appreciate the call give yourself some
grace and
intentionally default to kindness go
first in those relationships
and then just smile and walk away and
for god's sakes don't put your husband
in those situations
if you just have to find someone to vent
to about his ex-wife
find a friend find a counselor find
somebody um
write a letter to the editor i don't
even know if you can do that anymore can
you write letters to the editor anymore
in a paper
i don't think so i guess you can just
get on social media and thumbs down the
crap out of somebody that'll show them
um but whatever thank you so much for
that call ashley you're awesome y'all's
marriage is gonna be great
i can already tell